as if it wasn't already obvious Newt
Gingrich has now admitted that Donald
Trump is not draining the swamp now I
know many of our viewers and listeners
will hear me say that and I'll say well
obviously David and indeed the entire
draining the swamp meme was just like
most things in Donald Trump's campaign
just for show
just to bamboozle easily influenced
voters Trump campaigned on he's gonna
come in as the outsider to Washington
and clean up Washington and get rid of
special interests instead he stacked his
team with the likes of former Goldman
Sachs people which I'll get into in more
detail but maybe most notably Goldman
Sachs banker Steven minuchin who is
going to be the Treasury secretary he's
brought in Exxon plutocrat in chief CEO
Rex Tillerson to be Secretary of State
and now according to Newt Gingrich the
entire draining of the swamp thing yeah
that was just something for the for the
campaign Gingrich the former House
Speaker telling NPR's Morning Edition
that I'm told he now just disclaims that
he actually put out a tweet on December
18th saying the alligators are unhappy
about draining the swamp that is the
explanation for the nonsense about
subverting the electoral college and a
lot of people responding and saying whoa
whoa whoa wait a second there is no
draining of the swamp happening and
indeed Newt Gingrich telling NPR's
Morning Edition Trump now says the
entire draining the swamp thing it was
cute but he just doesn't want to use it
anymore Gingrich told NPR that he has
noticed the post-election change in
Trump's attitude to some issues
including the entire lock her up
investigate in jail Hillary Clinton that
was a primary theme in Trump campaign
events Trump now has admitted yeah
actually that was not something that I
was really interested in doing it's
something that worked really well during
the can
but now we don't care about it a
Gingrich said maybe he feels that as
president as the next president of the
United States that he should be
marginally more dignified than talking
about alligators in swamps obviously
that's bogus because on so many levels
Trump has been no more dignified if
you've watched his Twitter account he
clearly has been no more dignified no no
no this was just another one of these
meaningless campaign slogans meant to
bamboozle voters not shocking to me
probably not shocking to many of the
people in our audience I don't know that
I've seen a presidential campaign that
ended up having such little connection
to what ultimately were revealed as the
real plans of the administration lock
Hillary up oh no that was for the
campaign we don't actually care about
that now drain the swamp actually fill
it with former Goldman Sachs people
bring back Kol jobs actually that's not
really gonna work because of natural gas
prices send all the illegal immigrants
back to Mexico will actually Trump's
real plan will see fewer deportations
than we've seen under the Obama
administration and of course build a
wall in Mexico may pay for will pay for
it just not going to happen
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s